How to not cry while cutting onions?
Watch a comedy movie.
No.
When we cut onions,...
...chemicals like sulfoxides and enzymes are released which react to eventually form a gas.
This gas reacts with the lubricating liquid in our eyes and produces sulfuric acid,...
...which makes us cry.
However, if we freeze onions before cutting, then the temperature of onions drops.
Due to this, the sulfoxides and enzymes react slowly producing less gas.
And thus, reducing the amount of crying.
We can even wear tight goggles so that the gas doesn't reach our eyes.
It is also said that below the onion roots,...
...there is a bulb where the concentration of chemicals is more.
Hence, to avoid crying, we should first cut and throw that part.
Also, cutting an onion under running water washes away the chemicals.
Hence, we can also use this method to reduce crying while cutting onions.